COMMITTEE IS CALLED TO ORDER-
MADAM SECRETARY WOULD PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. NO OKAY SO WITH
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM WILL
BEGIN AS A COMMITTEE. HAPPY NEW
YEAR TO ALL THIS HEARING WILL
BE ONE OF TWO HEARINGS ON TO
YOUR BILLS. NEXT BILL HEARING
WILL TAKE PLACE ON TUESDAY
JANUARY FOURTEENTH AT ONE
THIRTY. PLEASE NOTE THAT OUR
GENERAL GUIDELINE FOR BILLS
HEARD IN THIS COMMITTEE JUST
ALLOW TESTIMONY FOR TWO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND TWO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
SPEAK FOR TWO MINUTES EACH
AFTER THAT I WILL ASK JUST FOR
YOUR NAME AFFILIATION. AND
POSITION. STAKEHOLDER GROUPS IN
ENTITIES AND NEITHER SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION WILL BE ALLOWED TO
GIVE TESTIMONY FOR NO MORE THAN
TWO MINUTES WHEN I CALL FOR
TWEETERS. THE MEASURE HAS MORE
THAN TWO ENTITIES AND THE
TWEENER CATEGORY ONLY TWO WILL
BE ALLOWED TO SPEAK FOR TWO
MINUTES. EACH. AND OUR FIRST
BILL ITEM NUMBER TWO- ENJOYS
SUPPORT SUPPORT A. B. ELEVEN
FIFTY FIVE MISTER RODRIGUEZ.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
I'M HERE TO PRESENT A. B.
ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE THIS BILL
WILL REQUIRE CAMPUS AFFILIATED
FRATERNITIES AND SORORITIES TO
ANNUAL REPORT AND PUBLICIZED
INFORMATION OF HAZING INCIDENTS
ON THE SCHOOL WEBSITE. HAZING
IN GREEK LIFE ORGANIZATIONS CAN
HAVE SEVERE IMPACTS BUT OFTEN
GO UNREPORTED. THE CENTERS
ABILITY OF NEW COLLEGE STUDENTS
TO MAKE INFORMED DECISIONS
ABOUT ORGANIZATION THE PLAN TO
JOIN. INCREASING PUBLIC
TRANSPARENCY IS KEY TO KEEPING
OUR STUDENTS SAFE AND AWARE.
UNIVERSITY OF THE COLLEGES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY HAVE
IMPLEMENTED A SCORECARD SYSTEM
SO THAT STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO
VALUABLE INFORMATION. THIS IS
ALSO AN OPPORTUNITY TO
HIGHLIGHT THE POSITIVE
CONTRIBUTIONS. AN ACHIEVEMENT
OF ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING
VOLUNTEER HOURS IN CHARITY. I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
AND I'M COMMITTED TO ADDRESSING
THE POINTS RAISED IN NOW THIS
IS THE NEXT COMMITTEE THANK YOU
MEMBERS ARE STRICTLY US FOR OUR
VOTE. ON A BI LEVEL FIFTY FIVE.
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. SEEING
NONE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. YEAH BUT I
DIDN'T CALL FOR WINNERS ON THE
BILL. IS THE THIRTY MARIE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
WE THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
ADDRESSING THE CONCERNS OF THE
ANALYSIS WE AGREE WITH THEM WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE OTHER TO ADDRESS THOSE
CONCERNS. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON TYLER REGULAR ME
AFTER THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
I WILL- SAYS HERE'S ASSOCIATE
MYSELF WITH THE COMMENTS FROM
MY COLLEAGUE FROM CSU THANKS.
GOOD AFTERNOON ALEX SPACE AT
THE ICC YOU I WOULD CONCURRENT
MY PREVIOUS- COLLEAGUES
COMMENTS THANKS THANK YOU. A
SCENE NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
INTRODUCING THE BILL. GREEK
LIFE AS WE ALL KNOW IS PART OF
THE COLLEGE EXPERIENCE AND FOR
MANY IT CREATES LIFELONG
FRIENDSHIPS AND PROFESSIONAL
NETWORKS. YET THROUGHOUT THE
CAR OF THE COUNTRY COLLEGES
STRUGGLE TO ADDRESS THE MAJOR
ISSUES OF HAZING THE MISUSE OF
ALCOHOL SEXUAL ASSAULT THAT TOO
OFTEN SEEM TO BE LINKED TO
FRATERNITIES AND SORORITIES
THIS LEGISLATION WILL GIVE
STUDENTS AND PARENTS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO OBJECTIVELY
EVALUATE EACH ORGANIZATION. AND
MAKE CRYSTAL CLEAR DECISIONS I
LOOK FORWARD TO SUPPORTING THIS
BILL TODAY AND TRUST THAT THE
AUTHOR WILL WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE STAFF AND
STAKEHOLDERS MOVING FORWARD TO
ADDRESS THE POINTS HIGHLIGHTED
ON PAGE FOUR OF THE ANALYSIS
AND NOW OF MADAM SECRETARY OF
WE COULD. NOT YET STILL HOW
ABOUT NOW NOPE. OKAY SIX ALL
RIGHT ONE MORE SO OKAY WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND HEAR THE NEXT BILL
AND COME BACK FOR A VOTE THANK
YOU. OKAY SURE THANK YOU. YEAH
I THINK SO MEMBER- RODRIGUEZ
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. FOR A
MANY OF THE REASONS WHY THAT
THE CHAIRS COMMENTED I SEE A
LOT OF REASON TO WANT TO HAVE
GREATER TRANSPARENCY ABOUT
WHAT'S GOING ON IN GREEK LETTER
ORGANIZATIONS- I SAW THIS UP
CLOSE AS A MEMBER OF A
FRATERNITY IN COLLEGE- AND ALSO
GOOD THINGS HAPPEN IN BAD
THINGS HAPPEN- I FEEL THAT
BEING OVERLY PRESCRIPTIVE IN
WHAT YOU'RE ASKING THE
FRATERNITIES TO PROVIDE- SET
SOME THINGS A LITTLE BIT TOO
MUCH AND STONE- WHERE THE
COLLEGES MAY BE ABLE TO COME UP
WITH SOMETHING. THAT IS MORE
REFLECTIVE OF WHAT SINCE MY-
PARTICULAR IN A CHANGING
SOCIETY. SO I'M GONNA VOTE NO
TODAY BUT I'D I KNOW THAT YOU
CAN WORK ON THIS MORE AND YOU
KNOW BE GLAD TO WORK WITH YOU-
AS WE DISCUSSED IN A PRIOR
CONVERSATIONS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU THANK YOU AND
NOW I'M SECRETARY. CALL THE
ROLL. INA. PRESIDENT CHOI
ARAMBULA BLOOM GABRIEL WHEN.
KILEY LEVINE LOW PATTERSON
SANTIAGO WEBER. AND DID THE
OTHER- WISH TO MAKE ANY CLOSING
REBEKAH TRAVEL OR SO I WOULD
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO MOVE. AND.
SO MOVED BY DOCTOR RUMBLE
SECOND BY A DOCTOR SHOWING- THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE CHOI
CHOICE I ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I
BLOOM BLOOM AYE GABRIEL- WHEN I
KILEY KILEY AYE LEVINE. LEVINE
NO LOW PATTERSON SANTIAGO WEBER.
SIX ONE WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU.
AND THE NEXT BILL- BILL ONE
MISS GARCIA. WELCOME THANK YOU
CHAIR AND MEMBERS WANT TO BEGIN
BY THANKING THE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING ON
THIS BILL AND I- EXCEPT THE
PROPOSED COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
OUTLINED IN THE ANALYSIS. ON
PAGE FIVE. AB NINE SIXTY EIGHT
WOULD REQUIRE THE CHANCELLOR OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
OFFICE TO ATTACK ESTABLISH. A
NATURALIST WORKFORCE MODEL
CURRICULUM BY JULY THIRTY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TWENTY TWO
THE ACADEMIC YEAR. CALIFORNIA
IS KNOWN FOR ITS BEAUTIFUL
NATURAL RESOURCES AND PRIDES
ITSELF ON CONSERVATION OF THOSE
RESOURCES. IN ORDER TO MAINTAIN
CALIFORNIA'S PRECIOUS RESOURCES
CONSERVE AND PROTECT THE
ENVIRONMENT WILLIS. SUPPORT OUR
WORK FORCE AFTER OF
NATURALISTIC CONSERVATIONIST IN
COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ARE USUALLY THE
STEPPING STONE FOR OUR WORK
FORCE ON AND SO I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE. OUT THERE
GETTING THE SKILLS THAT TO BE
THE STORE TO THE ENVIRONMENT
AND WE CAN BE I. HAVE A WITNESS
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MR
TURN MEMBERS I DANIEL THEN
CHAIR ON BEHALF OF COMMUNITY
NATURE CONNECTION WE'RE A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION BASED IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. THAT
PROVIDES UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES WITH ACCESS TO THE
PHYSICAL OUTDOORS AS WELL AS
TRAINING AND A CAREER PATHWAYS
TO ACTUALLY ENTER THE
NATURALIST COMPACT. FIELD I'M
ALTHOUGH THERE'S A NUMBER OF
REASONS THAT I COULD LAST AS TO
WHY WE SUPPORT THIS BILL ALL
QUICKLY VERY VERY BRIEFLY
IDENTIFIED THREE. THE FIRST IS
THAT THIS BELT WOULD ENABLE
MORE STUDENTS ACTUALLY ENROLL
IN THESE PROGRAMS TO ENTER THIS
FIELD ALTHOUGH. THERE ARE SOME
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WHO OFFER
SIMILAR PROGRAMS BECAUSE MOST
DO NOT HAVE EITHER THE
RESOURCES OR THE EXPERTISE TO
ACTUALLY CREATE THESE THIS
CURRICULUM FROM SCRATCH. THIS
WOULD ACTUALLY ALLOW. A TASK
FORCE OF EXPERTS TO COME UP
WITH A BASE STANDARD CURRICULUM
THAT THEY COULD- THAT WOULD
ALLOW THEM TO MORE EASILY AND
QUICKLY IMPLEMENT THIS
CURRICULUM IN THESE COURSES AT
THEIR INDIVIDUAL COLLEGES-
SECOND IS THAT. THIS WAY-
CREATE REAL JOBS NOT JUST
AGREES THAT BY AT REQUIRING
THAT THIS CURRICULUM INCLUDES
CLEAR PARTNERSHIPS WITH A
DIFFERENT ENTITIES LIKE STATE
PARKS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND NON
PROFITS LIKE COMMUNITY NATURE
CONNECTION. IT WOULD ACTUALLY
CREATE CLEAR PATHWAYS INTO JOBS
AT THOSE DIFFERENT SITES. AND
THEN THIRD I THINK IT'S
BECOMING UNFORTUNATELY CLEAR
THAT THERE IS A LACK OF WORK
FORCE IN THIS NATURALIST
CAREER- THERE ARE LOTS OF YOU
KNOW NEEDS LOTS OF- DISASTERS
THAT ARE HAPPENING Là TO PARK
CITY TO BE. LOTS SAYS THAT NEED
TO BE PROTECTED AND NOT MERELY
A ENOUGH WORK FORCE TO ACTUALLY
BE READY TO DROP CAREER SO THIS
WOULD ACTUALLY ENABLE- ANY HE
DID AN AYE. DADDY I FORCE TO
ACTUALLY AYE. THOSE CAREERS
ESPECIALLY TOP. THOSE
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITY MEMBERS
WHO ARE REALLY EXCITED AND IF
THOSE JOBS AND FOR THOSE
REASONS I'M WERE IN VERY MUCH
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND THINK.
THAT ARE FOR INTRODUCED.
SERVING SEE AUDUBON CALIFORNIA
AS WELL AS LATINO OUTDOORS ALL
IN SUPPORT. NATALIE NEXT ON
BEHALF OF MID PENINSULA
REGIONAL OPEN SPACE DISTRICT
AND FRIENDS OF THE LA RIVER IN
SUPPORT. ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. ANY TWEETERS. HELLO
MORGAN CAMINO BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS IS WITH THE
SUPPORT IF AMENDED POSITION I
WOULD LIKE TO REQUEST THAT THE
STATE CERTIFIED LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS IS BEING
COLLUDED AS ONE OF THE REQUIRED
CONSULTING ENTITIES DURING THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE CURRICULUM
DUE TO OUR STATUS AS A STATE
CERTIFIED CORPS AND OUR
EXISTING WORK IN PARTNERSHIP TO
DEVELOP SIMILAR CURRICULUM WITH
OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY COLLEGES WE
DO CONSIDER OURSELVES EXPERTS
ON THIS ISSUE. AND A POSITIVE
ADDITION TO THESE CONCERTS
CONVERSATIONS- WE THINK AUTHORS
OFFICE FOR THE PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO A POSITIVE
RESOLUTION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
I JUST AND SILICON CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE WE DON'T HAVE AN
OFFICIAL POSITION AT THIS TIME.
AND WHAT WE DO WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
ISSUE FORWARD. AND WORKING WITH
US ON THE AMENDMENTS HOWEVER WE
DO HAVE A CONCERN AROUND THE I
JUST ESTABLISHING A PRECEDENT
FOR CREATING CURRICULUM A
REQUIRING CURRICULUMS STATUTE.
OUTSIDE OF OUR NORMAL PROCESSES
FOR CURRICULUM AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT. THANK YOU. CHEN
MEMBERS ALSO WEBSTER DOWN THE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF THE
COAST AND RANCHO SANTIAGO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT SALA
LINER COMMENTS WITH A CHANCE
WAS OFFICE. ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
DOCTOR CHOI. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA THIS IS
AN INTERESTING- BILL I HAVE TWO
QUESTIONS AND NUMBER ONE IS
DOES THAT MEAN THAT- TO BECOME
THEN SO CALLED A NATURALIST. IS
A PATHWAY TO. FOR THE TWO
LEADERS TO JOB BUT- AND OUT
WILL IT THE REQUIRED TO BECOME
THE NATURALIST OR I IS THIS
JUSTO. ONE OF THE. COURSES SO
FOR EXAMPLE OR ANY OTHER MAJOR
SO CAN THEY GET A JOB AS A
NATURALIST YEAH I MEAN WHICH IS
HELPING TO CREATE A TO WORK
FIRST DEVELOPMENT SO IT'S NOT
AN ACTUAL DEGREE ON AND SO
THERE'S A LOT TO THE POLICE TO
ENTER INTO THIS WORK BILL WE
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE IS IN MY
DISTRICT FOR EXAMPLE I ONLY
HAVE COMMUNITY COLLEGES. AS THE
HIGHER AT THAT'S THE GROUP ARE
A LOT OF MY STUDENTS ARE GOING
BUT THEY'RE NOT BEING EXPOSED
TO THIS CAREER IF YOU WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT THAT THE
GATEWAY THAT THEY'RE BEING
EXPOSED ARE BEING EXPOSED TO
NONPROFIT THAT THE NATURE
CONNECTION AS A PROGRAMMER
READY TO LEAD YOU INTO THAT
DEGREE OR INTO THAT PROFESSION
ON THREE DIFFERENT
ENVIRONMENTAL PROGRAMS AND
DIFFERENT CAMPUSES OR OTHER
JOBS ARE THE CORPSE ALSO AND SO
I DO TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION
THEIR REQUEST AND I WILL BE
WORKING WITH THEM TO GET THEM
TO A SUPPORT. SYSTEM ON AND SO.
I JUST ANOTHER AVENUE TO. TOOLS
ARE AWARE THAT THIS IS A
POSSIBILITY AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. SO ENTITIES ENTITIES
ALIKE IN NATURAL CONSERVATION.
WOULD PREFER SOMEBODY WHO
FOCUSED ON THIS KIND OF A
STUDY. SO THAT'S WHAT I GET.
YEAH SO I WOULD ACTUALLY- THERE
ARE SEVERAL PROGRAMS LIKE THIS
THAT DO EXIST WHEN I WOULD
POINT NOW IS THE UC NATURALIST
PROGRAM- WHAT. THE INTENTION
REALLY AS THERE IS TO BOTH
INFORM STUDENTS THAT THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY AND THIS IS A
CAREER PATH THAT DOES ACTUALLY
LEAD TO. SUSTAINABLE AND
FAMILY- SUSTAINING JOBS. SO
WHAT IT WOULD ESSENTIALLY DO IS
IT WOULD CREATE A SPACE FOR
THEM TO START BECOMING
INFORMED- INFORM THEM ABOUT
WHAT THOSE CERTIFICATIONS AND
TYPES OF JOBS. WOULD BE. AND
THAT WHAT THE BILL WOULD DO IS
ACTUALLY REQUIRE THEM TO.
PARTNER WITH LOCAL OR STATE OR
GOVERNMENT ENTITIES THAT COULD
COME IN AND ACTUALLY CONNECT
THEM TO PROGRAMS OUTSIDE OF THE
COLLEGE. THAT COULD THEN
PROVIDE THEM WITH THAT.
CERTIFICATIONS THE TRAIN THE ON
THE GROUND- WORK AND THE ACTUAL
CAREER PATHWAYS AN ACTUAL JOB
PLACEMENT OPPORTUNITIES. TO
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS SO FOR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SO WHEN THE-
OUR FOCUS ON THIS CURRICULUM
THEN THEY WILL GRADUATE THE
WITH THE A DEGREE IN. SOMETHING
THAT TORE STATUS THAT IS SET
DROUGHT WHITE. WE THIS IS
ACTUALLY NOT CREATING A DEGREE
IT'S UNTIL IS A SO WHAT I MEAN
I THINK THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
IS IT GONNA BE WHAT THE
CERTIFICATION WHAT IS IT. SO I
THINK THAT IT WOULD REALLY BE
IT- UP TO THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE AND THEN THAT TASK FORCE
THAT'S IT REALLY IDENTIFYING
WHAT IS THAT INTEREST AND WHAT
IS WHAT IT WHAT ARE THEY
ACTUALLY AVAILABLE AND WHAT IF
THEY WANT TO OFFER TO THE
STUDENTS I COULD SEE THAT TEY
COULD PROBABLY DECIDE THAT THEY
WOULD DO YOU WANT TO OFFER
MUCH- HIGHER DEGREES HERE OR IT
COULD BE. MORE OF A KIND OF
CONNECTION COURSE SO I THINK-
BY ALLOWING THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE AND THEN I THINK IT'S
CALLED THE SENATE- CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE SENATE OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT THAT'S CAN ACTUALLY
APPROVED THAT CURRICULUM IT AND
BRING IN EXPERTS WHO ARE IN
THIS FIELD AND KIND OF KNOW HOW
TO CREATE A CURRICULUM AND ARE
OUT ON THE FIELD DOING THIS
TYPE OF WORK. BY REQUIRING THAT
THEY ALL COME TOGETHER TO
DEVELOP THE CURRICULUM I THINK
THAT'S HOW THEY WOULD REALLY
IDENTIFY WHAT ARE THE DEGREES
THAT THEY MIGHT WANT TO OFFER
IS THAT NOT ACTUALLY SOMETHING
THAT'S TANGIBLE ARE VIABLE OR
THAT FOLKS ARE INTERESTED IN OR
HAVE WHAT DIRECTION THEY WANT
TO GO OUT. INTO CREE
FLEXIBILITY SO THAT THE ANSWERS
OF THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO
CREATE SOMETHING THAT FITS THEM
BUT ENSURING THAT THERE IS AT
LEAST SOME SORT OF AN AVENUE
THAT WE ARE INFORMING. THE
STUDENTS ABOUT THE POSSIBILITY
OF NATURAL AS OF THE CAREER-
BUT WE ARE TRYING TO CREATE
FLEXIBILITY HERE SO THAT. NOT A
ONE SIZE FITS ALL. NO I DO SEE
A OF GREAT POTENTIAL THAT THE
GOOD CURRICULUM CAN BE
DEVELOPED- AND THEN I'M COMING
FROM A CITY OF FOUR OR FIVE WAY
A ONE THIRD OF ALL CITY IS OPEN
SPACE AND THEN APPLYING
CONSERVATION CORPS. I'M IN THE
THAT'S WHAT THEY DO HOW TO
MAINTAIN AND THE OR SO AT THE
SAME TIME TO MAKE IT OPEN TO
THE PUBLIC TO ENJOY SO TO GET
THE GOOD BALANCE. AND THE
UTILIZING THE VOLUNTEERS IN
ALL. THAT ALONE WOULD REQUIRE
SOME SOME LEVEL OF SKILL SET.
SO IF FOR THIS IS A INTRODUCED
A FOR SOMEBODY. I WOULD LIKE TO
MMHM BECOME A SPECIALIST A
MAJOR IN THE COURSE TO HAVE A
DEGREE IN COLLEGE THEN THE FOR
YOUR UNIVERSITY IS A WOULD
HAVE- A PATHWAY TO LEAD TO A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN THIS-
NATURALLY SCORES OF THIS IS
SOMETHING I THINK FOR A TO
THINK ABOUT AS A NEXT STEP. I
DEMAND THAT SEPARATING THE
DIRECTION THAT WE ARE TAKING
WITH THIS BILL BUT WHILE
ALLOWING SOME FLEXIBILITY TO
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE I THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES BUT THAT IS.
THAT IS OUR HOPE A LOT OF TIMES
STUDENTS IN MY DISTRICT THAT
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE ARE NOT
AWARE THAT THIS IS EVEN AN
OPTION TO THINK ABOUT A DEGREE
AND THAT THEY STEP TO COULD BE
TAKING. AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE BEFORE THEY TRANSFER TO
STEP INTO THAT SPACE AND SO UP
FOR ME FOR EXAMPLE WERE WORKING
ON A RIVER VENTURES PROGRAM FOR
THE REAL HONDA AND DALY RIVER.
ON AND WE LIKE THEIR IT'S TV
LOCAL HIRES AROUND THAT BUT-
WHEN A NATURALIST. TRAINING
WOULD BE A NATURAL POSITION. I
TO GET YOU INTO THAT SPACE BUT
WE DON'T HAVE ANYTHING LIKE
THAT AND IN MY COMMUNITY. AT
ALL AND SO I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT AS WE DEVELOPING THIS
GREAT PROGRAM I'M ABLE TO HIRE
AND TRAIN LOCAL FOLKS. ALONG
THE WAY WHILE I ALLOW THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. AND THE
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS TO CLEAN THE
CONSERVATION CORPS THAT THE
THOUGHT EXPERIENCE TO TELL US.
THIS IS THE BEST WAY TO DO IT
WOULD ONLY TO START FROM
SCRATCH AND- ONE STEP. OUGHT TO
COULD CAUSE THAT FITS INTO THE
STEPS ARE ALREADY OUT THERE
INCLUDING. PROGRAMS THAT DO
EXIST AT THE UC'S MY CAL STATES
IN THE FOUR YOU'RE NEVER CITIES.
THANK YOU. NOT SEEN ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS- MISTER
SEE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE SO WE HAD A MOTION BY A.
DOCTOR WEBER SECOND BY MISTER
LEVINE. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE OF MADAM SECRETARY
THE CALL THE ROLL MEDINA AYE
MEDINA AYE CHOI CHOI I ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA I BLOOM BLOOM AYE
GABRIEL GABRIEL I- WHEN- WHEN I
KILEY KILEY AYE LEVINE LEVINE I
LOW LOW I PATTERSON PATTERSON I
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO I WEBER
WEBER I. TWELVE ZERO YOUR BILL
IS OUT. AND NOW WE WILL GO TO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IF I COULD
HAVE A MOTION. BY DOCTOR
RUMBULA. AND SECOND BY DOCTOR
CHOI MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. MEDINA AYE
MEDINA AYE CHOI CHOI I ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA I BLOOM BLOOM I
GABRIEL. GABRIEL I IRWIN- WHEN
I KILEY KILEY AYE LEVINE LEVINE
I LOW LOW I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I
WEBER WEBER I. TWELVE ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS PASS WE
HAVE ONE BILL ON CALL. ITEM.
TWO A. B. ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE
GABRIEL. GABRIEL I LOW LOW I
PATTERSON PATTERSON AHRI
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I WEBER WEBER
I. ELEVEN ONE AT BILL IS OUT
AND WE ARE ADJOURNED